bonsoir dave perkins persie d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france crise qui
défend la probité du scrutin limogé
c'est le dernier en date
bon c'est pas vraiment surprenant mais
pour vous le supporters de donald trump
as quand même ça ne fait pas un petit
peu beaucoup de limoger tous ceux qui
sont finalement contre vous d'autant que
c'était un préfet sionnel de la sécurité
je vais essayer de remettre les choses
en perspective
crêpes ça apparemment fait un très bon
travail pour l'administration au cours
des quatre dernières années
mais voici ce qui est arrivé ou surtout
retrouver face à une réalité qui se
déroule devant nos yeux
donald trump s'apprête également à
porter plainte 5 c'est que le système de
vote de mignonnes et à d'autres ce thème
de contre comptage des votes sont très
faciles à pirater et ont été inventés
conçu pour être facilement piraté et
pour pouvoir manipuler les résultats
la lenteur de ces systèmes a fait
mesurer la venezuela a dit qu'il a avait
réussi à ajouter un million de nouveaux
votes afin de s'assurer que mathieu
reçoit réélu c'est ce même logiciel qui
a été utilisé dans beaucoup d'états des
mines et de les compter aux etats unis
l'idée qu'il soit facilement piratables
qu'il était utilisé afin de manipuler le
résultat d'élections que tout cela est
simple à faire je veux dire qu'il faut y
avoir une enquête car il y à des
irrégularités dans cette élection il ya
des moments lors du mardi de l'élection
ouf
la courbe des votes pro maiden augmenté
de manière verticale ce qui a permis à
joe biden de prendre l'aventage sur
donald trump alors qu'il n'avait pas
auparavant
et c'est une possibilité mathématique
c'est la preuve qu'il y ait de
manipulation du logiciel du système de
comptage des votes afin de changer les
résultats dans des états clés ce qu'on
appelle les étapes qui vont au temps des
villes telles que atlanta détroit dans
le michigan et ses informations existent
ces fouilles avoir raison il faut qu'il
y ait des enquêtes et je pense qu'une
fois qu'il y aura des enquêtes on va
découvrir le pot-aux-roses et chris rsa
a pris position a dit non tout va bien
rien de mal ne s'est passé de notre
avion nouveau coupé mais j'ai une
question quand même à vous poser nous
dit oui voilà c'est pas possible un
moment donné on a vu la courbe de joe
biden augmenté mais certains vous diront
que c'est aussi le fruit des votes par
correspondance vous savez bien que ces
votes ont été comptabilisés plus tôt à
la fin et que c'était souvent
traditionnellement plutôt pour joe biden
ces votes par correspondance vous le
dénier vous en tant que supporter de
donald trump vous n'êtes pas du tout
d'accord les votes par correspondance ne
sont pas responsables de ces cookies
voici ce que cet ingénieur du venezuela
le décompte dans ces états étaient
interrompus avant jamais le décoince n'a
été interrompue aussi tard la raison
pour laquelle le compte était
interrompue et c'est la raison pour
laquelle donald trump à se tourner vers
les tribunaux pour tous et que les
personnes qui s'occupaient du des
collèges avaient découvert que les
formulaires dans la machine ne suffisait
pas pour renverser la majorité
pour donald trump donc ils ont dû
interrompre le décompte est relancé
je n'avais qu'une nouvelle formule qui
leur a été transmis par internet
lorsqu'ils ont relancé le compte la
formule était bien plus rapide et à
avantager bien plus les démocrates c'est
pour cela qu'il ya ceux plus que ce
n'est pas à cause des votes par
correspondance ils n'ont pas été tous
compter un à moulins le problème c'est
que les machines ont été modifiés afin
qu'il y ait plus de vote pour joe biden
proportionnellement à donald trump
il ya environ il ya environ cinq
millions de voix d'écart
il ya un million cinq millions de voix
d'écart dans cette élection à ce que
vous pensez qu'il ya eu autant de fraude
que ça de même si on considère qu'il
peut y avoir eu des fraudes est ce qu
elles sont aussi importantes que ça
selon vous l'ingénieur qui a conçu ce
système peut créer un million de faux
suffrages au venezuela alors sans aucun
doute il peut en créer 5 millions aux
états unis
mais il le fallait à ces deux fortes que
pour remporter les grandes villas dans
les états pivots c'était leur cible dès
le départ le whisky gin le michigan la
géorgie et certains autres états qui
n'ont pas encore déterminé le vainqueur
mais ce système était utilisé dans 30
états et le new york times ça a fait un
exposé est bien exposé il ya des années
sur le danger de ce système on voit un
professionnel de l'informatique expliqué
un étudiant comme un pirate et cette
machine donc cette machine et ce
logiciel sont très faillible des
politiques démocrates sont son plein il
y a plusieurs années il ya deux ans et
aujourd'hui soudainement ces mêmes
démocrates restent silencieux sur le
sujet parce que ils utilisent maintenant
à leur profit en tout cas ce que vous
vous dites évidemment c'est la thèse
défendue
c'est normal puisque vous êtes
supporters républicain par donald trump
il l'a encore dit mercredi c'est une
élection truquée j'ai gagné aujourd'hui
clairement monsieur perkins qu'est ce
que vous attendez
de la justice nous fait confiance à la
justice de votre pays pour faire la
clarté sur cette élection puisque vous
êtes convaincus que votre poulain la
remporter je pense que cela va se
retrouver devant la cour suprême est
assez rapidement mais nous n'avons pas
encore terminé de construire notre cas
car la fraude est très large et notre
cas audois ne doit pas avoir la moindre
faiblesse car sinon on se servira de la
moindre faille pour invalider tout le
cas où les démocrates sont vraiment sur
le chantier de guerre ils pensent qu'ils
ont déjà gagné le jeu baden se déclare
président élu mais ça n'est pas vrai
pour être président lui soit il faut que
l'autre candidat reconnaît sa défaite où
il faut que le collège électoral
vous consacrez et cela n'est pas encore
arrivé joe biden s'appelle le président
élu pour influencer l'opinion du peuple
américain pour leur faire croire qu'il a
déjà gagnée donc cela va se retrouver
dans un cour suprême et je suis persuadé
que c'est donald trump qui va reporter
cette affaire merci beaucoup d'éleveurs
perkins analyse politique et supporters
de donald trump merci d'avoir été avec
nous dans vu de l'extérieur ce soir